but let's speak now to our next i guess
who is that denise francescan who
represents marine le pen's a party
abroad
looks like you're in for a pretty
disappointing night
a little bit of course you know we were
expecting to win however um she was only
one candidate against against macron you
know gathered like so many people around
him and she still gathered like more
than three percent i mean so it's it's
in defeat it's still a it's still a
significant victory in terms of how many
millions of people are now you know
voting for her
[Music]
do you think that this is the end of
marine le pen's leadership of the party
it's the third time isn't it that she
has attempted to win
the french presidency will it be the
last
she mentioned that that you know running
third person campaign is exhausting so i
mean i i don't think she will run fourth
time however i think she will still be
you know involved in politics i mean
obviously she has you know she's a
strong personality uh she's a strong
political figure
so i'm sure she will be involved in the
next in the next election next few years
but uh in terms of you know another
presidential campaign um i'm not sure
right now
uh what do you think will happen uh to
the far right in france as well because
marine le pen of course uh went some way
to soften uh the image of the far right
uh talking more about the cost of living
for example rather than some of the more
hard-line policies on immigration but
then at the same time
there are challenges in that space
aren't there if you look at the
performance of as a more free from
example in the first round
how do you think the uh far right is
going to react
i mean
she was talking i mean and her party was
talking about you know subject like
immigration that that that could
you know could be considered as as far
right was like decades ago but now all
the political parties agree that you
know there's issue in terms of security
in terms of of deregulated immigration
so because of that she was able to talk
about other topics uh i think that
candidates that will only stay on on
issue about immigration for instance i
think it's a i don't think there's a win
in that i think you need to talk about
different topics
and when you look at the polls
obviously you know the cost of living
the the power of purchasing was very
very important for the past five years
you know with the emmanuel macron like
destroying you know basically uh you
know everyday life people every working
person a hard time to you know to live
during those five years so i think the
angle she choose about you know putting
or i would see most of her program
into the cost of living i think that was
a very smart move uh of course we still
have to talk about immigration we have
to talk about you know those topics but
there's it's not just one topic you know
we need to talk about a lot of different
things
uh eric zamor who we're just talking
about the kind of right wing polemicity
got 7.1 of the vote in the first round
has come out to say that the nationalist
movement must join forces in his words
we can't win without alliances do you
think
that
that view is now going to be become part
of the mainstream thinking in the right
that they need to join forces and that
it's a fractured right that won't be
able to win
but it all depends how we define you
know the the the right wing i mean if if
being from the right means that you
don't care about social you don't care
about cost of living then of course this
option will lead to nothing will lead to
nowhere if you know being you know a
strong right-wing person means also that
you're gonna you know care about the
cost of living and care about people who
are suffering on i would say on a social
standpoint then this this angle is
actually is for sure the one that will
be winning you know in in the next few
years because that's that's people in
france now they want security
whether it's an institutional security
or social security uh they want they
want to be able to work they want to be
able to live decently so you need to
combine those those elements and i think
uh you know defining this policy has
right-wing or extreme right-wing i think
it's definitely passe i think we are now
in a complete different you know
scenario with people who
let's say are the globalists and and
daily find that way and you have you
know the rest of population that are
struggling and and those people
unfortunately are completely unheard
even the the people voted for milan
shown they are very close you know in
terms of the program to what marine was
saying during the campaign
so i think there will be a lot of
movements uh from that standpoint in the
combination of what we can call the
right the right values with the social
values
it's interesting what you say about the
similarities there between the far left
and far right and you're right of course
to say that you know the interventionism
of le pen
uh and melashon is actually quite
similar do you think that actually in
france it's more of a movement away from
the establishment that we're seeing
yeah and look if you look at the uh at
the pool and if you look at who voted
for mccoy in the first round and i'm
sure we're going to have the same result
right you know for uh for today is you
have
the students and those who still live
with mom and dad and the retirees vote
massively for macron in other words
those who are not
in the the working system yet or those
who have you know worked in in the 70s
or the 80s where the situation was
completely different and those who voted
for marine le pen where i would say the
french from like the 25 years old to 55
were those who are actually still
working and they're experiencing you
know the harsh cost of living so so
that's why you know i believe that the
next angle in terms of how the society
in france will evolve is definitely by
combining those you know those two key
elements
okay thank you very much for coming on
sky news and sharing your thoughts thank
you